supongamos que trabajo en un restaurante
donde me pagan 10 dólares la hora pero
además de eso gano propinas por ahora
esta expresión de aquí representa lo que
ganó en una hora dada ahora podemos
notar que la cantidad de propinas puede
cambiar drásticamente de una hora a otra
por ejemplo a la hora de la comida hay
mucha gente mis propinas suben mientras
que una o dos horas después ya hay menos
clientes y entonces mis propinas bajan
entonces la propina aquí toda esta
palabra la consideramos una variable
puede cambiar de un momento a otro así
por ejemplo en un momento dado a la hora
de la comida cuando hay mucha gente
podría estar recibiendo digamos 30
dólares de propina así es que en esa
hora mis ingresos totales son de 10 + 30
dólares vamos a ponerlo aquí en esta
hora mis ingresos totales son de 10 más
las propinas es decir 10 más 30 dólares
así que eso va a ser igual voy a hacerlo
con otro color esto es igual a 40
dólares
ahora supongamos que a la siguiente hora
los clientes bajan ya pasó la hora de la
comida
quizá el restaurante de al lado tiene
una gran oferta y entonces mis propinas
descienden drásticamente a digamos cinco
dólares en esa hora entonces regresando
a esta expresión mis ingresos durante
esa hora son 10 dólares mi salario por
hora más los 5 dólares de propinas lo
que me da un total de ingresos durante
esa hora de 15 dólares como puedes ver
en esta expresión el valor de mis
ingresos cambia de acuerdo al valor de
la variable propinas ahora en álgebra no
verás palabras completas para designar
variables a los matemáticos nos da
flojera usar palabras completas entonces
usamos sólo letras quizá entonces en el
contexto de este ejemplo veremos que la
expresión se representaría como 10 + p
donde p representa las propinas que
recibo en una hora y entonces qué pasa
cuando p es igual a 30 bueno cuando p es
igual a 30 déjame escribirlo aquí abajo
p es igual a 30 recibo diez más treinta
igual a 40 dólares durante esa hora que
pasa cuando p es igual a 5 cuando p es
igual a 5 recibo 10 más p que ahora es 5
10 + 5 es igual a 15 dólares durante esa
hora ahora quiero que quede claro no
necesariamente tenía que haber sido p no
necesariamente tenía que haber sido una
letra aunque en álgebra tradicionalmente
usamos una letra podríamos haber escrito
como 10 + x donde x son las propinas por
hora aunque no es tan natural como la
letra p de propinas o también podríamos
haber escrito como 10 + digamos estrella
donde estrella representa las propinas
por hora aunque esto no es tan intuitivo
pero espero que esto te haya dado una
idea general de lo que es una variable
simplemente es un símbolo que representa
valores que cambian valores que varían y
es por eso que les llamamos variable